the White House says President Trump's
former bodyguard did nothing wrong by
taking the president's medical records
from his New York doctor's office last
year
dr. Harold Bornstein told NBC News the
unannounced visit felt like a raid and
he reportedly says that a letter he
signed praising mr. Trump's physical
condition was dictated by the patient
himself vici Jiang is at the White House
with the latest we do good morning good
morning bianna releasing the health
records of candidates during a
presidential campaign is customary and
in 2016 then Canada Trump insisted he
was the picture of good health but
you're right this morning we're learning
what the president's former doctor
claims his team did to make sure that
image remained and to ensure his
personal records remained private I
don't know folks you think Hillary would
be able to stand up here for an hour in
doing this during the 2016 campaign
President Trump repeatedly criticized
opponent Hillary Clinton's health and
stamina while painting himself as a then
70 year old man in perfect shape I feel
as good today as I did when I was 30
the Trump campaign released this
December 2015 letter from his longtime
personal doctor Harold Bornstein that
declared if elected mr. Trump I can
state unequivocally will be the
healthiest individual ever elected to
the presidency Bornstein later said he
wrote the letter while a trump campaign
limo waited outside but Tuesday
Bornstein told CNN the words were not
his but president Trump's he dictated
that whole letter I didn't write that
letter Bornstein told CNN I just made it
up as I went along well as medical
records as pictures anything they could
find Bornstein told NBC News that three
men including former Trump bodyguard
Keith Schiller and Trump Organization
lawyer Allan Gardens showed up at his
office unannounced in February 2017 to
take the president's medical records
I feel raped raped frightened Bornstein
said the incident took place two days
after he told the New York Times that
mr. Trump took propecia a drug to
promote hair growth
and it certainly is not a breach of
medical trust to tell somebody they
think will be sure to grow their hair on
Tuesday the White House pushed back
denying it was a raid as a standard
operating procedure for a new president
the White House medical unit took
possession of the president's medical
records the White House says those
records were seized at the request of
the medical unit but has not clarified
why that former bodyguard mr. Schiller
was also present John would you Thanks